there is a guy who wants to become a
human Ken doll that's right we've got
some pictures of him his name is Rodrigo
Alves he has spent more than $250,000 to
become a human Ken doll I mean these
pictures are just wild we'll get into
that in just a sec but first now that
you've seen what he looks like let's get
a quote from Rodrigo himself he says I'm
pretty aware that I'm far from
perfection I'm not deluded and I know
that I'm not the most good-looking guy
I'm just aiming to be the best that I
can possibly be
I really believe that everything that
I've done to myself is an investment it
is Who I am all right so I every time we
do stories like this and we've done this
kind of thing it's usually with women or
we did a story a couple weeks ago on men
that literally where silicon women's
outfits people have all kinds of weird
fetishes and you know into different
stuff and do all kinds of things to
themselves I try not to be too glib
about it because obviously there's some
pretty clear jokes we can make here but
there's there's a psychological element
to this and there's also an element of
it's his life and his body and if he's
not hurting anybody that who cares so
let's jump off with that yeah I mean if
he's not hurting anyone anybody who
cares I do sort of feel bad for the guy
though he's had three nose jobs and he's
gonna have another one he's addicted to
having plastic surgery you know but what
I would really like to see is for the
human Ken doll to hook up with the human
Barbie doll and there is a Barbie doll
right so they need to get together I
have a feeling he may not be in tonight
I'm pretty far beyond you know what I'm
talking about
what do you think about this he has body
dysmorphia yeah you know he talked about
being bullied as a kid they made fun of
him for having a big nose so that's
probably why he's had so many nose jobs
because it's something he's very
self-conscious about and I also feel bad
for him because if you read the comments
on articles like this or videos that I
looked up about him people are horrible
in the comments they say you know you
know really mean things insult the way
he looks call him you know a freak and
stuff like that and I just think that
that's really kind of up for them
to do because here's somebody who
clearly is you know has body dysmorphia
is not confident in themselves and
you're making them feel where
you're putting them down yeah like the
sort of irony of this whole thing he
obviously was uncomfortable with the way
he looked to start but then by doing
this in a public fashion because
obviously if he's posting this stuff
publicly he's okay with people talking
about it but that the reaction then is
the complete reverse really obviously
was doing it to get a positive reaction
and this is people love to find anyone
who's different and point at them and be
like oh my gosh I'm better than you so
let me insult you yeah you know I how
much of this so getting away from
whatever his psychological issues may or
may not be and obviously we can't
diagnose him here how much do you think
of this is just that we live in the
selfie nation we live in a time when
selfie sticks are a real thing and I was
talking about a couple weeks ago but I
was in New York and I was walking
through Times Square and I literally saw
dozens of people just staring into
screens with selfie sticks in front of
them instead of actually what was going
on we're all taking pictures of
ourselves doing all kinds of stuff we're
all guilty of it myself included so how
much is just that forgetting his psyche
like forgetting it I think it's a huge
influence on him I mean the media in
general you can't every screen whether
ature your phone or your iPad or your TV
it's all about how you look yes you know
it's all about image and it's just
magnified to such a crazy extent
nowadays that I think it has definitely
if he are obviously already had
something internal going on right but
this just amplifies it yeah I mean I
it's not just him - yeah okay sure you
know he's an extreme case but like you
said there's people with selfie sticks
walking around when they're not looking
at what's going on around them I mean
people are very you know vain
and it's you know no one's really
excluded from that nowadays and I feel
like there's a lot of people getting
plastic surgeries for things that they
don't necessarily need - yeah I always
try to you know I advise friends like no
you don't need to do that to yourself
you don't need a nose job you don't need
a boob job just be happy with yeah but I
mean at some point you know if something
is gonna make you feel that much better
I mean I guess do whatever do you you
know make yourself if if it actually is
making him feel better I don't know what
the answer to that is but this story was
making me think about Bruce Jenner
because he's now transitioning to be a
woman supposedly they're gonna do a
reality show about it now his whole life
and his whole family is based in this
reality thing I want to
empathize
and if he truly feels that he is a woman
and he's going to do this but then at
the same time he's opening himself up to
all of this criticism it's exactly what
I'm saying about this guy like if you're
gonna do this publicly then you're gonna
get on for the exact thing that
you're trying to fix so it's really like
psychologically Bor yeah I mean you get
better be ready and it's in a way like
if you like you said if you're gonna do
it and so publicly there's gonna be
backlash ya know unfortunately that's
the way it works what are you guys
making the doctors that do this so in in
a case of this and that not the Ries
janitor situation but in a case of this
where someone's clearly living out some
quest for perfection that can never
exist but the doctors will always take
the money you know what I mean Joan
Rivers at 80 something I love Joan
Rivers but at 80 something was still
getting work done you know I mean is
there an ethical piece of that you know
I personally I mean I I graduated with a
degree in biomedical sciences and
actually almost went to my lake I went
to medical school I almost became a
doctor and I could never ever have done
something like this just because I I
wouldn't feel right about it but if this
is something that they really want
they're gonna find somebody who's
willing to do it you know and if you as
the physician feel like you are you know
fulfilling a request for somebody you're
making somebody happy right you know so
I mean at what degree is a boob job
unethical right you know so for as many
doctors as have certain ethics you're
always going to find one you can always
go to another country right you know
it's big business all right what do you
think is this going too far if he's not
hurting anyone then is it okay let us
know in the comments right down below
and don't forget to subscribe